bonjour à tous qui connaît bitcoin il y
en a déjà pas mal c'est bien qu'ils en
art et vous devriez pourtant donc
bitcoin ce qui est intéressant c'est que
si on regarde une maxime de dostoïevski
qui disait l'argent c'est de la liberté
frappé et finalement c'est de ça que
j'ai vous parlez moi c'est de liberté
parce que bitcoins est une monnaie mais
c'est bien plus et c'est aussi et
surtout l'alphabet de la monnaie
l'alphabet de la monnaie l'alphabet de
la liberté un alphabet politique quelque
chose sur lequel on peut construire et
donc pour commencer je vais vous
rappeler rapidement ce qu'est bitcoin
pour que tout le monde soit au même
endroit et donc le bitcoin c'est avant
tout un protocole donc un protocole
c'est une manière d'échanger de
l'information
une manière standardisée d'échanger de
l'information et donc les protocoles
sont extrêmement importants pour tous
les systèmes des changes
donc bitcoin au lieu que ce soit de
l'information classique c'est de
l'information transactionnel dire qu'on
s'échange mais de la monnaie des
bitcoins ou sur ce protocole il ya des
règles établies et donc par exemple on
sait qu'il n'y aura que 21 millions de
bitcoin ça c'est une des règles du
protocole on sait qu'on ne peut pas
dépenser deux fois ce qu'on possède donc
ça c'est également une des règles du
protocole une des règles des changes et
donc sur ce protocole c'est change de la
monnaie et comment on a réussi à créer
une monnaie numérique
eh bien on a réussi à créer de la limite
dans l'espace numérique quel cyberespace
et c'est la première fois qu'on arrive à
créer les limites dans ce cyber espace
parce que quand j'en vois une photo à ma
grand mère j'ai toujours la photo quand
j'en vois un bitcoin à ma grand mère
j'ai pu le bitcoin et c'est ça la
différence majeure et il faut se dire
que c'est bien la première fois qu'on
arrive dans cet univers qui est
totalement intangible a créé une limite
physique en quelque sorte a retrouvé de
la limite donc on s'échange une once
échange quelque chose qu'on peut appeler
monnaies vu que celle ci a une valeur
actuellement ça vaut
dollars mais on parlera pas ici du
courroux de la spéculation
on va plus être sur les concepts et
essayer de voir ce que ça peut nous
apporter
et ensuite bitcoin c'est aussi un réseau
alors qui dit réseaux dits communauté
parce que un réseau c'est avant tout des
gens connectés entre eux c'est des
machines
dans le cas de bitcoin vu que c'est un
protocole le protocole est compris par
les machines et des machines tournent
toute la journée pour faire tourner
bitcoin mais c'est un réseau d'humains
tout autour du monde qui croient en
bitcoin et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'il a de la valeur parce que pour que
ces bitcoin est de la valeur il faut
bien que des gens les achètent et donc
et confiance dans ces bitcoin est donc
ce réseau bitcoin il est co construit
tout autour du monde par des gens qui
veulent simplement mais s'investir dans
ce projet et ce qui est intéressant avec
ce réseau c'est qu'il est horizontale et
un changement cosmologique par rapport à
tout ce qu'on voit actuellement
généralement on est sur des structures
très verticale avec un chef un leader en
suisse leader et la dent bitcoin
renversement n'y a pas de chef
y a pas de patron aucun patron on sait
même pas qui a créé le bitcoin ccc pour
dire à quel point le père est absent
entre kiel et le leader n'est pas là et
donc on a un réseau qui est horizontale
un réseau dans lequel tout le monde peut
s'investir et en même temps dans lequel
tout le monde peut participer librement
un réseau où il n'y a pas de sang sur un
réseau inclusif où on a besoin de
montrer rien à personne et ce réseau il
est horizontale mais il est aussi
autonome autonome parce que dans bitcoin
c'est le protocole qui gère les échanges
alors soit des machines exécute ce
protocole mais les règles font que le
réseau devient autonome et si on va au
coeur du mot autonomes csa musan parce
que à auto à odos en grec ancien
signifie même lui même le même et nomos
la loi donc en fait on a on efface un
objet ici qui fait la loi par lui même
et il ya quelqu'un qui souvent d'une
maxime et qu'il a d'ailleurs qui a
permis de la faire connaître et qui dit
qu'au 10 lots lawrence lessig et
finalement bitcoins et l'exécution même
de cette maxime c'est à dire que avec
bitcoin code is love c'est à dire que
absolument tous toutes les règles du
protocole s'exécute et font respecter
cette loi entre guillemets parce que
tout le réseau d'humains et de machines
ne font que respecter ses règles et ne
peuvent que respecter ces règles
et enfin une dernière partie bitcoin
c'est un consensus décentralisée ça veut
dire c'est des gens qui n'ont pas qu'ils
ne veulent pas forcément se faire
confiance qui ne veulent pas forcément
les mêmes intérêts mais qui doivent
trouver un consensus aller dans une
direction trouver un point d'entente
pour créer un système qui marche et
finalement ça marche parce que ça marche
depuis maintenant neuf ans et ça marche
24 h sur 24 7 jours sur 7 sans aucune
autorité centrale
donc on a véritablement là un alphabet
de la monnaie dans le sens on peut
construire de nombreuses choses dessus
un alphabet plus ou moins politique
parce que on a tendance à dire la
technologie est neutre
moi personnellement j'y crois pas parce
que pour moi les développeurs les
codeurs comme aux appels sont les
écrivains que sartre décrivez il ya 50
ans les écrivains selon sartre sont
forcément engager tout écrit tout écrit
va porter de l'engagement
et finalement les développeurs sont
engagés ils sont engagés et dans le
bitcoin c'est encore plus visible parce
que là où émerger bitcoin ce sont des
serres crypto narshingdi crypte
anarchiste pas dans le même sens que
cryptocommuniste il ya 30 ans c'est pas
des communistes cacher ou des
anarchistes cacher ses des cryptes
anarchiste parce que la cryptographie
est au coeur de leur pensée avec la
confidentialité et la vie privée et
l'anarchie
et leur mode de pensée politique donc
l'absence de chef
donc ce qui est intéressant là dedans
c'est que on a une étape prise de
conscience que le code peut permettre
d'établir des structures politiques et
fait donc de bitcoin est en quelque
sorte un alphabet politique
alors pourquoi un alphabet un alphabet
parce que bitcoin va être une structure
sur lequel on peut construire
donc pour l'instant de caunes est avant
tout une monnaie une monnaie c'est déjà
incroyable d'avoir réussi à faire une
monnaie une monnaie c'est un pouvoir
régalien qui n'avait jamais été
renversées et qui là est renversé grâce
à une communauté tout autour du monde
qui s'entend sur ce logiciel est donc
cette décentralisation permet
l'établissement d'une nouvelle norme une
nouvelle norme monétaire une nouvelle
norme dans les échanges et l'importance
de la norme et est capital dans le sens
où suffit de regarder un peu dans le
passé pour voir qu'on est con est passé
dans la globalisation avec la
normalisation des contenaires alors ça
peut paraître complètement stupide mais
si on n'avait pas établi des règles très
strictes dans la manière et dans l'est
dimanche dans la dimension des
contenaires on n'en serait pas là
aujourd'hui 98 pour se rendre du trafic
mondial de marchandises se fait par la
voie maritime
grâce aux comptes name normalise donc
finalement ici on a une nouvelle norme
de communication qui est universel parce
qu'elle est dans le cyberespace
le cyber espace ce territoire où les
frontières sont extrêmement différentes
il ya plus de frontières physiques les
frontières sont uniquement linguistique
vous ne pouvez pas aller je pense sur
l'internet chinois pour la majorité de
vous parce que vous ne parlez pas
chinois
la frontière est uniquement linguistique
la majorité d'internet par l'anglais la
majorité du monde parle anglais et
finalement c'est ce qui fait que une
grande partie de l'internet du web nous
pouvons la consulter
donc finalement si on pense à cet
internet universel ce cyber espace ce
nouvel espace où les frontières sont
différentes
on a la même chose du côté des machines
parce que les machines
finalement elles ont besoin d'un
protocole commun qui puisse être adapté
sur différentes machines parce que si
bitcoin et mettez une frontière
linguistique
elle ne pouvait pas être sur tous les
ordinateurs tous les téléphones
portables on perdrait cette universalité
et du fait que ce soit un protocole on
l'obtient et on obtient une nouvelle
norme donc pour communiquer alors
pourquoi pour communiquer parce que la
transaction
finalement c'est une communication ça
steam parfois que des gens vous font une
transaction
et c'est en même temps leurs
négociations de commerçants à un client
et en même temps la transaction l'objet
de les changes
et quand on arrive à se dire que les
paroles sont des transactions eh bien on
peut imaginer de nombreuses autres
choses avec cet alphabet d'accord cet
alphabet de la conscience cela confiance
pardon excusez moi donc toutes ces
choses là qu'on peut imaginer ce sont
par exemple le vote le vote finalement
c'est une transaction vers un candidat
dire que je donne un jeton un candidat
en quelque sorte et on additionne le
candidat qui a le plus de jetons
non finalement avec bitcoin j'ai des
jetons qui sont monétaire mais si je
fais d'autres jetons je m'inspire de cet
alphabet justement pour créer un autre
un autre logiciel ou si je m'appuie sur
bitcoin pour créer quelque chose je peux
par exemple créer du vote du vote qui ne
nécessite aucune autorité centrale et il
faut bien voir à quel point c'est fort
dans le sens où les votes électroniques
pour l'instant sont tous quasi
catastrophique
il n'y a quasiment pas de
de vote électronique qui ne se sont pas
mal passé et la raison cela c'est la
centralisation parce que la catastrophe
arrive souvent avec la centralisation
lorsqu'il ya une autorité elle est
faillible
elle est courue petit bhl notre
connaissance en tout cas et on le voit
aussi dans huit mois il d'ailleurs pas
c'est amusant les journaux m reprendre
les faillites plus ou moins de bitcoin
où les vols de bitcoin mais finalement
tout s'est tous ses vols tout ces
brigands 10 sont le fait d'une
centralisation c'est parce que des
agents détenait les clés des bitcoins de
personnes à leur place donc quand on
retourne à la centralisation même avec
bitcoin on a dit on a des pépins parce
que on a des failles et on a de la
corruption possible
donc ce que propose bitcoins et un
alphabet de la conscience dans le sens
où il n'y a en quelque sorte plus besoin
de se faire confiance on dit ross laisse
en anglais il ya besoin de n'accorder de
la fois qu au réseau go système cas cet
ensemble d'individus qui fait tourner le
protocole et qui peut le mettre à jour
donc forcément parfois dans une
communauté
il peut y avoir des dissensions s'est
pas fait toujours facile de trouver un
consensus était centralisé mais on
avance doucement dans le temps soit il
ya des petits blocages mais on avance et
bitcoin continue d'avancer et tout le
monde peut y participer tout le monde
peut proposer une mise à jour est donc
dans ce monde où la confiance où on a
une communauté totalement auto géré la
confiance elle se manifeste par la
fiabilité de la cryptographie et des
mathématiques sur lequel repose bitcoin
est finalement je peux envoyer de
l'argent à quelqu'un être absolument
sûrs et lui il peut être absolument sûr
que ce n'est pas de la fausse monnaie
parce que le réseau meules garantie et
le protocole ne le garantit
et donc finalement on passe d'un système
où on est obligé de faire confiance à un
tiers très souvent une banque un état un
système où on peut se faire confiance
entre pairs parce qu'on est sur un
système horizontale
donc là je pense que vous voyez de plus
en plus se construire cet alphabet
politique
bitcoin est soit un projet technologique
une aventure technologique mais c'est un
projet politique
politiques parce que il nous amène plus
d'équité par l'horizontalité nous amène
plus de participation active la
démocratie souvent doit être pensée
comme un système politique qui demande
de la participation de la part des
citoyens et finalement dans cesti dans
ses systèmes des changes décentralisée
tout le monde est obligé de participer
au système ou pas mais si si le s'il
veut être un noeud s'il veut héberger
une partie du réseau il doit le faire
complètement et finalement on a un
système où il ya 8000 témoins sur ce
réseau huit mille deux mille
participants actifs avec beaucoup plus
de d'autres personnes qui juste utilise
le réseau mais il ya 8000 personnes qui
peuvent qui ont des deux et qui voit
passer ces transactions et ce qui est
amusant c'est que ces transactions
finalement comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est du langage et aux transactions on
peut attacher du langage les ya toutes
les transactions sont horodatées dans un
grand livre de contes qu'on appelle la
blocs chaîne et que tout le monde et que
tout le monde certifie que le réseau
certifié donc finalement c'est
transaction là peuvent contenir des
informations d'autres informations
et là on peut de suite pensé à la poste
qui nous fait payer entre guillemets des
recommandés mais là je peux certifier
moi même cette preuve de date et d'heure
finalement pour la première fois je
pourrais très bien certifié une
invention tout comme je le ferais avec
une enveloppe soleau tout seul tout seul
avec 8000 personnes ville personnes que
je ne connais pas mais qui ont vu passer
mon information à telle heure à telle
date tel jour et ça c'est la force au
site ce réseau ça veut dire que
là je vous avais quelques cas d' usage
mais on peut penser à l'énergie pour
certifier de par exemple un compteur
électrique
quand on aura des productions bien plus
décentralisé mais on peut penser à
énormément d'autres domaines comme la
santé les l'identité l'identité est un
cas d'usagé extrêmement important parce
que c'est aussi une possibilité de
réappropriation de l'identité
actuellement ne fait que délégué notre
identité et avec des systèmes tels on
pourrait se réapproprier les noces
identité numérique est donc selon la
nouveau avec tous et alphabet mérite
d'être observés au moins un petit peu et
peut-être mérite votre participation
parce que il ne vit que par ça il ne vit
que par tout un tas de personnes autour
du monde qui participent il n'y aura
personne pour faire le service client ou
rester
après la disparition de possibles
personnes qui ont quitté ce réseau donc
finalement ça va être peut-être un peu
paradoxal par rapport à tout ce que je
viens de vous raconter mais je vous
demande de me faire confiance
mais de jeter un coup d'oeil à tout ça
merci
[Applaudissements]